where does your relationship stand now I
am not with Jed anymore
Hannah Brown reveals she's no longer
engaged to Jed Wyatt and asks a fan fave
Tyler Cameron on a date your incredible
guy and I'm a single girl let's rewind a
bit Hanna handed out her final rose and
accepted a proposal from Jed Wyatt as
her season came to a dramatic close on
Tuesday you told me in our very first
interview that you didn't want to end up
with a lying sack of poo does that
happen well we don't know who I end up
with yet and we will have to continue to
what we do now fans finally got to see
the fallout from Jed's relationship with
another woman prior to coming on the
show come to light
I have sobbed on the floor I felt like
my whole especially in that moment like
my whole life just like caved in and
everything that I thought was true and
real wasn't I have been mad as hell the
engagements over or not together it's
just that's not what I said yes to
during after the final rose Hanna
confirmed the pair is no longer together
and they came face to face for the first
time since they officially ended things
well my heart gets broken a lot for a
lot of different reasons the 25 year old
musician admitted he's still in love
with Hanna I regret all this so much
regret my decisions
and I wish you know it was different and
I wish that I could change the past but
I can't but my life for you
I don't think it won't ever leave me
it's just something that isn't there to
say but Hanna is ready to move on and
feels stronger than ever my feelings
really just for Brooke with that and I
don't I don't love you like that anymore
although the former pageant princess
said goodbye to fan favorite Tyler
Cameron which he took like a champ hurt
but I'm still gonna be your biggest fan
rooting for you
now wouldn't you and Jonathan buzz
herself to accept a proposal from Jed
she admits she's still holding out hope
for the Florida native I feel I feel
like I should just leave when the pair
came at face to face after their split
in Greece the crowd went wild
including Bachelor fanatic Demi Lovato
who was front and center for the action
she got to witness Hannah taking fate
into her own hands and being bold am
asking Tyler out and leaving bachelor
nation's jaws on the floor I just
thought maybe we could go her drink and
just say it don't you just tell me what
did you just ask Tyler out on a date
I can tell you later Hanna was a guest
on Jimmy Kimmel Live where she said
again just how excited she is to get
that drink with Tyler did you have a
drink on your way over here it didn't
have quite enough time to even order one
from the bartenders right now when is
this gonna happen do we know I mean I
just talked to him for the first time I
know she also admitted her family was
worried she would end up back with Jed I
actually called my mom the other day to
tell her like some news and she was like
oh don't tell me you're back with that
boy and really my dad goes oh hell no
but still she doesn't want the world to
hate him I don't want him to hate him
well they do when it comes to who Hanna
wants to be The Bachelor it's so weird
picking the bachelor from my
ex-boyfriend
it seems she wants to keep Tyler out of
the running now a can't be Tyler cuz
you're going for drinks with him then
we'll see where the drinks go I thought
Peter is really crazy I want them to
have happiness so yeah yeah okay you
don't work out better for them than it
did
[Music]